a very special guest I'm sure betting
likes that you don't often get that when
you come in the club do you
well Grandmaster been Feingold is doing
commentary at King side diner with a GM
Ian Rogers who's come all the way from
Australia to enjoy the time here and do
work at the Ziegfeld Cup but then
welcome to the show thanks Marie it's
great to be here yesterday was amazing I
mean it must have blown your mind you
guys must have been going crazy watching
all the exciting chess yeah it looked
like you know I was in a little bit of
trouble and then when he sort of
equalized we were like oh well I guess
there won't be five decisive games and
then all of a sudden there was becoming
clear what was gonna happen
and I wouldn't have expected that
anywhere and so as the start of the
tournament is really fantastic for this
event okay so we didn't get ten win ten
wins in a row
we got a draw MBO and and Aronian
decided to make peace so we booted them
out of here we didn't even interview
them but but the other games there are a
couple of games that are interesting so
let's take a look at the games let's
just start with the game with far beyond
oink and in Magnus so far the most
interesting thing as Jen pointed out is
that Fabiano's use a lot of time to get
to this position which doesn't seem that
special for ya and and luckily even
though I was I was taken away from my
live coverage we have a good replacement
and Lauren's Trent who as you know is
doing a lot of commentary for your event
soon and of course he's a manager of
Fabiana Caruana and he was not happy he
was actually very happy with his
position but he was not happy with the
29 minutes think about Bishop a2 he's
like why why the long think in a
position that he said this should just
be good for white and well they were
sort of arguing if it was very nice for
white or just a little bit nice and then
it seems like fob young maybe change his
mind thought he had a nice position but
after Bishop a2 and which is a
reasonable move but to think so long
well his manager obviously was upset
yesterday when he was in the commentary
with us so now he's he's getting upset
again yeah I'm gonna have to talk to him
when he does commentary for our event
since Fabiano is playing in that one as
well we need some objectivity when
you're doing commentary
of course so let's then get off this
game and look at this one
between Geary and Wesley so this game is
looking good for white but at the same
time he does have any palm breaks how is
he gonna make hay in this position right
and actually white had more than one
plan and it wasn't sure which was
correct and he's not yeah I mean like
one plan was to play for h h4 h5 which
he decided not to do unless he changes
his mind the other which you guys were
pointing out when i was standing outside
watching was to eventually play Knight G
1 to F 3 which we were looking at before
and Eden was surprised because Ian
Rogers thought this line was not very
good for black and Wesley just sort of
played it and just said ok I'm here and
what are you gonna do to me and it seems
like Gary's not really sure what to do
and I think blacks getting closer to
equality now I think I would agree with
you there now let's get to some real
action on the board well first of all
this one with grease Chuck and Anand
it looked like gristick wood doesn't go
for a dark square domination but now
he's captured on d5 which seems very
surprising I would think I don't be
relieved to see that's not the move we
were looking at over at Kings side yeah
actually we were very surprised about
the move Bishop to d7 earlier in the
game and Ian Rogers had a very good
explanation he said obviously after
Bishop g7 Grisha didn't expect this move
so it's time for a 20-minute think so
always play move the grishnack isn't
expecting because we got to get him in a
time trouble yeah it looked like a nun's
playing a little bit funny this game and
maybe white had a little advantage but C
takes d5 is really surprising me
yeah that's pretty shocking to me as
well and finally we go to what starting
into B well it looked like it's gonna be
a bit of a barn burner at first but now
it's seems just like a standard pawn
sack for dark square domination we
surprised it the way talk will all play
this position you know I was surprised
at how quickly they were playing because
usually when you're sacrificing a pond
or playing really unusual moves like f5
at E 5 and mixing it up there is some
nice long thinks there and they were
tilling it sort of quickly so he
sacrificed a pond without giving it
super deep thought and we thought he had
just about enough compensation and b3
was
played when I was a king side but that
was a movie predicted trying to play
Bishop B to get some dark squares and
yeah I think it's actually probably
dynamically equal he probably is just
enough compensation for a pond but I
don't think any more so I think a car is
doing pretty well now stylistically is
this something that he car was gonna be
very confident realizing that he has to
defend against Opel of bit of an
initiative with that dark square bishop
that's gonna be unopposed for the rest
of I think it's okay because the car was
one of the few 2,800 players who likes
his Knights I mean most of us really
like our bishops and I also think that
cargo plays the Dutch a lot and he's
used to having a pawn on f5 and you know
we all I'm sure you ask your agrees with
all of having an extra pawn so I think I
think a car was gonna be okay with this
and maybe even worse than the other
players of the tournament being a pawn
up having the beautiful knight on d5 f5
he's not so worried about so I think
he'll be able to defend this position
and yeah I think he's fine here last
year you predicted mvl winning the whole
thing that didn't quite happen is this
this guy named Fabiano car on and showed
up and played some pretty moves who do
you think this year I are committed I've
been telling people for three weeks that
I thought her car was gonna win because
he's just having a fantastic year
he's play he's lost almost no games I
think he's lost one and he seems to have
really matured his chest seems to get
better and better like every few months
and I think this is really his year and
well he showed it yesterday he played a
very mature game and very patient and I
think he has a really good overall style
he can play slow positional boring chess
and grind it out or he can play
tactically like we see this game which
is now becoming more positional and I
think he can just roll with the punches
and he's doing it better this year than
he's done it before so I still expect to
Carla's gonna win the event it seems
like he has been the steadiest player
even when he doesn't play great by his
standards especially you know you come
and you say wow great game and you're
saying I wasn't a game buddy but he's
just showing like you said a certain
maturity and he said it if I don't lose
then it's hard for these guys to beat me
but I guess it makes sense if you're not
losing but it seems like he just kept
that attitude which is very different
from his attitude very consistent this
year unlike previous years where you
sort of expect a lot of wins and losses
and here we're not seeing the losses
we're seeing really steady play and so
far in this tournament even in this sort
of complex position he made it
sort of dry where he has an extra pond
and it's not too dangerous so I think a
really good place so far might be
interesting to see you would you predict
him as the next challenger to Magnus
especially watching Magnus is shocking
fall he's lost about 40 rating points
from his high I wouldn't be surprised
and I sort of half jokingly said well
maybe more than half jokingly that I
wonder who will be the highest rated
player in the world when this tournament
is over and well I mean if top eleven
Accardo keep winning and Magnus keeps
having bad results I mean his last 10
rated games he has five losses and m-v
on the other hand he just got stopped
today he won four games in a row if you
take Beal and two here into account so
some of these players are on the rise
and Magnus has to find his form again so
I wouldn't be surprised if Nakamura or
Cara Juana or even somebody else as is a
big challenge for for Magnus next time
well it's definitely getting interesting
the world chess thanks as always for
your insights Ben and get back over to
the diner save some food for me all
right
Grandmaster been fine to go one of the
great commentators we have here at the
Sinquefield Cup come on down and join us
and him at the kingside diner
you got chess happening everywhere here
in st. Louis